[Music]
happy half birthday Rose
I just want to find my daughter
[Music]
I'll always be there for you no matter
what
foreign
[Music]
You Are My Precious Rose
you didn't care
together
I'm so sorry
I love you
dad
[Music]
s
sometimes I've lost or afraid
try to imagine what he might have said
to me
no matter
you're imminent demise
I love you how will that anything happen
to Rose
got this
[Music]
[Music]
I'm Kento kenoshita the director of the
Winter's expansion
gave his life to protect Rose and in the
end you see how she's grown
what kind of person is 16 year old Rose
that's what we wanted to explore so we
decided to have her at that age in this
expansion
said you had something important to tell
me
[Music]
she's trying to get rid of her unwanted
Powers but to do that she is forced to
return to the origin of her Misfortune
we thought that concept had a lot of
potential for an interesting story so
the setting this time is the realm of
Consciousness going back one more time
to that Village
the word nightmare is synonymous with
fear for instance if you've ever had a
childhood fever that caused a nightmare
even if they only last for an instant
like the feeling of being attacked by a
giant doll or something else similarly
so completely unrealistic can remain as
a fragment of a memory for the rest of
your life I wanted the core of the
feeling of fear to come from the kind of
memories and Nightmares that still haunt
people to this day
we wanted to choose characters that
would interest people who didn't play
The Mercenaries mode but would be
interested in playing a different type
of character
there are characters called Lords and
plain is them allows you to perform
amazing skills and attacks that a
regular human could not being able to
play them was more fun so that's why we
chose those characters
we balance things to ensure that as
little time as possible is spent waiting
for enemies to appear for instance if a
player doesn't finish off an enemy it
will chase after the player we made
adjustments like this to raise the tempo
and increase the fun of defeating enemy
after enemy
in an FPS you experience the game world
as if it's through your own eyes so it
can be incredibly scary to play a horror
game from that perspective
there are some players out there who
might find it too scary or experience
motion sickness in the first person
perspective they might not enjoy the FPS
genre
so we wanted to make a third person mode
for those players
to enjoy the game to its fullest
while there's still a sense of immersion
and fear with a third-person perspective
when the player character dies it
doesn't feel as much like you yourself
or die and you can enjoy playing it as a
game to confront the fear that it
creates which is a very different
experience I think third person mode is
a perfect way for people to return to
Resident Evil Villages as both a game
and an experience wouldn't it be okay to
show Ethan's face he gave that question
some thought
so even in third person mode if you try
to turn the camera to see his face Ethan
will look away and you're not quite able
to get a good look
each of the three editions are
interesting in their own way and we hope
you really enjoy the expansion please
look forward to it thank you
thank you